fake your death and don't wake daddy
because we have episode 5 of night
fliers and this one promises to be a
smashing good time
a young Cynthia heiress hides from her
father and what appears to be a
flashback from when she was a child you
can see the stained glass windows here
are the same ones found in Cynthia's
cabin we catch a quick glimpse of
Cynthia's father whose eyes and mouth
have been scratched away Carl and Rowan
continue to catalogue chunks of organic
material from the probe chunks that
belong to Carl and even contain his
teeth the team decided they needed to do
something once and for all about Cynthia
mommy says she can try to get into the
system to contain her but if she fails
it could mean she's lost in there
forever
Lonnie hops in the memory sphere to
share one of her most tragic memories
this man here who we saw in previous
episodes as the tied up man and who will
know a little bit more later on was
teaching Lonnie how to cultivate her
technological skills but unfortunately
they're caught and she's forced to break
his hands with a hammer I'm self-taught
and whoa lemis installed two neural
ports saying she needs the extra
bandwidth if she's gonna find Cynthia
and here's Mel acting all concerned even
though last episode she was getting
freaky with Aris fail stages a mock
medical emergency likely him acting out
after last episodes weird hallucination
with Agatha the team leaves him alone
when out of the blue comes net other
than Murphy he recounts his story of how
his family died to an l1 that no one
should have such powers if they can't
control it hopefully this will put bail
on the right track to take his power
seriously which he'll need to do if he's
gonna talk to the Volk Hren
Agatha suggests to Carl that they'll can
be used to help Lonnie in case she gets
into trouble and we saw the writers hint
at this last episode when they'll could
feel what Lommy was going through when
she connected herself to the probe this
would also help they'll feel like he's
part of the team he's brought in to
Cynthia's cabin and asks everyone but
Lonnie and Eris to leave while Eris
connects her to the system
Rowan invites Tessa for a sexy date to
see his space blood because she might be
able to explain why the probe cells
simply won't die Lonnie arrives at grey
wing the mansion Eris's grandfather
built this dude the mansion has
essentially become a manifestation of
the ship with firewalls acting as doors
long aventures
further in and uncovers the same
portrait of Cynthia found in heiresses
cabin on the night flyer young Cynthia
appears who wants her doll back and
warns her of the man upstairs but it
seems the only person she should be
afraid of his older Cynthia who attempts
to cut her head off missing and breaking
the fabric of the program Lonnie is able
to escape and ventures into the basement
always a great choice but is essentially
sent on a wild goose chase since it
seems Cynthia can control every aspect
of this world cornered by Cynthia Lonnie
asks who the man upstairs is but is
subsequently choked and fail can feel it
too
Agatha asks Carl about Joy's therapy and
it's a little bit awkward Lommy awakens
after being unconscious for two full
days they'll manage to pull her out of
the program but things are never what
they appear in night fliers and this is
all a dream within a dream some real
inception ship who is all a ruse to buy
Cynthia enough time to break through
Roy's firewall and trap Lonnie instead
with Cynthia now on the loose she begins
to take her revenge and depletes the
oxygen in Carl's room Oggy runs to the
rescue but even weirder is how Agatha
somehow knew he was in trouble
almost like an l1 could Carl and Agatha
check up on Lonnie who fail says is now
trapped and Agatha convinces him to go
back inside and try to get her back
meanwhile Lamia ventures upstairs about
to unleash Grandpa Eris before she
stopped by Cynthia who explains he used
to beat her we also learned that the man
Lommy smashed with a hammer in her
memory was her father
ouch Lonnie opens the door trapping
Cynthia in the room with her abusive
father while she manages to put a
firewall over the door they all brings
her out and she's reunited with the team
heiress Asif her mother was sent
somewhere peaceful
oh-hoh heiress carl caves and sends the
message of him ending things with joy he
just can't be around a woman who refuses
to remember their daughter back in the
medbay Murphy gets his tan on well
failed digs into Murphy's memory feeling
the pain of his dead family we can see
bloody hands covering his face and skin
ripped off his chest mommy gives Mel the
cold shoulder pissed off that she knew
about Captain eras perving them while
they had sexy time and it looks like
Carl's wasted no time in getting over
his wife as he visits Agatha for a
late-night makeout sesh but what I find
interesting is how he said she was in
his mind it was her voice that brought
him back there has to be a connection
with this and how egg
as somehow knew about him losing oxygen
in his room Rowan and Tessier go over
the blood samples and Rowan theorizes
about the ability to send messages
across galaxies in particular how the
probe was sent back not to communicate
but to listen it's revealed that Augie
and Cynthia had a romantic past he calls
her beautiful and she says she will
always love him this likely sowing the
seeds for Augie eventually releasing
Cynthia so she can once more terrorize
the ship not to mention how the episode
ends with Cynthia banging on the door of
her prison and gray wing how long it'll
hold we can only guess thanks for
watching everyone if you liked the video
make sure to give it a thumbs up for the
next five episodes I'll be doing one big
ending explain so make sure you're
subscribed with the Belon to know
exactly when it comes out and until next
time remember daddy loves you very much